rencontre.
fréquentent le Zytynsky's Deli
depuis des années.
Ces temp
est un lieu de rencontre,
et c'est la crise ukrainienneee
qui est au centre
des discussions. Le commerce a
de kilomètres de l'Ukraine,touté
de près, surtout Myron,
dont le fils, un diev avec sa ce
et ses deux enfants.
- Myron n'est pas le seul
à se lever tous les matins
dans l'angoisse que l'escalade
HELENE LEVKO
- On a ds qui restent
là-bas encore, puis ils ont peur
parce qu'ils voient tousnt cach,
tous les tanks qui arrivent,tu ,
ça fait peur parce que pour,
tu sais, on sait pas
qu'est-ce qui peut arriver.
- Et surtout, on se demande
pourquoi
l'Ukraine est encore aujourd'hui
menacée par Moscou.
ANATOLI HAYDUK
- Pourquoi? Tu fais rien,
dans une vie démocratique dansl,
choisit le gouvernement puis
tout, maaux Ukrainaux Ukrainauxs
qu'est-ce qui est bon
pour les Ukrainiens.
- À quelques pas, on retrouvenne
de Montréal, le point de service
pour la majorité des 18 000
Ukrainiens dans la métropole.
Ces deux institutiien
la preuve que la communauté est
soudée, et elle l'est d'autant
soldats russes à la frontière,s.
- La sol- La sol- La sol- La so,
deux principes que connaît bien
le prêir l'espoir d'une sortie
de crise pacifique. Chaque j
il prie pour le peuple
ukrainien.
Église ukrainienne orthodoxe- C,
très dure, très difficile.
On prie,qu'il n'y a rien qui est
hors de contrôle de notre
du Seigneur, on prie que
le Seigneur va faire que ça soit
- Tous le nous avons sollicités
ont préféré s'abstenir
de commenter.
Ici Aimée Lemieux